un bon soir françois chossy merci d'être
avec nous aujourd'hui sur air france
alors on l'a vu en israël accuse est la
finul d'être obsolète de son côté la
finul souligne que la situation dans
cette zone est l'une des plus calmes de
son histoire récente alors qui voit-on
écoutez je dirais que moi j'étais dans
la finul en 1982 déjà les israéliens
tenait le même discours donc il n'y a
pas grand chose de changé dans le
discours des israéliens à chaque fois
qu'on doit voter le renouvellement du
mandat
là nous sommes dans le renouvellement du
mandat donc tous les ans pour que les
forces de la finul en godet 1500 hommes
restent sur place et assume l'ambition
alors qui faut-il croire c'est une très
bonne question
reconnaissons que les israéliens comme
l'a dit votre journaliste n'a pas
vraiment non pas vraiment respecté les
règles et interviennent quand même assez
régulièrement bien moins que dans le
passé mais interviennent dans le sud
libre maintenant est-ce que les libanais
et surtout le hesbollah respecte aussi
le la résolution 1701 qui a été décidée
en 2008
en fait non et si vous prenez le dernier
rapport qui précède le vote d'une telle
résolution
écrit par le général commandant par le
commandant la force et d'autre part
présenté par le secrétaire général du
terreau s
on voit bien que le hezbollah continue à
creuser des tunnels faits d agressions
cible et cherche à introduire des des
soldats de l'autre côté de la frontière
et d'autre part continuer à dissimuler
des armes dont de part et d'autre les
deux sont coupables
vous l'avez dit ça vous à quelques jours
du renouvellement du mandat de la finul
présentes au liban depuis 1978 on a
commencé à comprendre avec votre
dernière réponse mais
mais la présence de la finul et est
toujours aussi nécessaire dans la région
oui tout à fait parce que la mission de
la finul et d'abord engager sous le
chapitre 6 ce qui veut dire qu'il n'ya
pas d'agression d'agressivité ni dans q2
de mesures de combat à la une mission
humanitaire et elle a surtout un rôle
que il n'a pas été cité c'est celui de
favoriser le retour de l'armée libanaise
armée souveraine dans le sud du liban et
à ce titre on peut se demander
d'ailleurs même si l'armée libanaise
fait tout ce qu'il faut pour permettre à
la finul de bien se déplacer contrôler
et faire sa mission ce qui n'est pas
toujours le cas et d'ailleurs le général
commandant la force s'est plaint
justement que l'armée libanaise était
pas toujours coopérative
donc voilà donc la finul est utile
chaque année quand on vote le
renouvellement du mandat on met en
question sa présence et à chaque fois la
finul reste je doute très fort que la
finul sens dès aujourd'hui et quelle est
la place du hezbollah dans le liban
contemporain
alors je me contenterai de la zone sud
puisque toute façon nasrallah a bien dit
qu'il continuerait à cacher des armes et
à alger contre israël mais ces zones de
prédilection pourquoi parce que c'est au
contact d'israël est l'ennemi du
hezbollah c'est israël ça c'est le
premier point
maintenant si j'élargis le la réflexion
sur le hezbollah au liban aujourd'hui le
liban a une force civilo-militaires que
je qualifierais c'est le hezbollah qui a
une force armée qui fait ses preuves en
syrie qui est effectivement un danger
d'abord pour l'état libanais mais aussi
pour la paix régionale et c'est un
mouvement qui est aussi qualifié de
mouvement terroriste et qui veut la
destruction d'israël
bon et vous avez évoqué il ya quelques
instants leur relation je crois que
l'iran ou votre journaliste précédent le
hezbollah est quand même a été créée par
l'iran est soutenu par l'iran
tout ceci fait effectivement quelque
chose d'assez explosifs dans la région
sans baver jeu de mots comment vous
voyez un l'évolution des tensions entre
israël et le liban pour l'instant la
finul eux justement dans le cadre de sa
mission fait bien interposition mission
de maintien de la paix israélo baelemans
respecte cette présence d'abord elle est
demandeuse fois qu'on puisse en dire
puisqu'elle se saluer assure un glacis
dans lequel des forces internationales
patrouillent et font quand même régner
une certaine insécurité pour ceux qui
voudraient passer donc israël à mon avis
a besoin tout à fait de la finul
maintenant chaque année il est demandé à
la finul d'être plus offensive notamment
ce qui était demandé d'ailleurs par le
chef d'état major de l'armée israélienne
il a été demandé de pouvoir fouiller les
maisons chez les libanais pouvoir qu'il
ait pas d'armes d'explosifs ou autre
roquette et le gouvernement libanais a
dit non ce qu'on peut comprendre ça d'un
côté mais il faut reconnaître que si la
finul n'est pas capable d'exercer tout
son mandat de contrôle de la sécurité et
de la présence d'armement elle ne
remplirait pas totalement sa mission or
c'est comme un peu le cas aujourd'hui
merci beaucoup françois souvent c'est
d'avoir été avec nous ce soir sur arte
france rappelle que vous êtes un général
de brigade et expert en géostratégie